what's up hello
can i help you
hold up hold up all right guys um
i'm here with my sisters
um
so i wanted to know
i'm glowing
so bright
all right
today we're gonna have the sex talk
oh my god hannah i just had the
premarital sex talk in theology class
and you know how weird it is for a
middle-aged man to talk to you about why
you have to wait for sex yeah um
i don't
i think it's weird that they talk about
sex in schools i think it's so weird but
anyways so let's talk about sex in here
autistic kid in my class and he was like
why would anyone ever have sex that's so
gross and i'm like dude you are a
product of it
so what questions do you guys have about
sex
i don't have how long will this take
he's not the not sex she means to talk
oh my god
okay guys
do you want to buy me a condom so i can
like hold it out the car window and see
how big it would get
no
wait
all right guys so when a man and a woman
love each other very much because up
until the age of like 10 i thought sex
was just kissing and rolling because
that's what you told me
okay well
i know
um
okay so when a man and a woman love each
other they already love each other they
could just pay good money
like
okay when a man and woman are attracted
to each other very much
they decide
to get naked
[Laughter]
all right 911
they decide to get naked
um
they don't need to get naked though they
just have to have their parts exposed
how do you how do you know this
hannah is it's one plus one equals two
how do you know that
it's common sense
hi and everyone is this emergency all
right guys so what do you what do you
need to know crazy what do you what do
you need to know i'm a little scared
what do you need to know how to get you
out of my room and stop talking about
okay so
now remember
now remember okay i'll record you too
with those cairns on the street girls
are judged for having sex right
yeah and then guys are like hey good job
you [ __ ] that chick yeah yeah it's a
double standard it's not fair but it's
real
it's real we can't
so you know
be careful with that stuff
because the husband you get someday is
dependent on the type of girl you are
right
so i just yawned now i'm crying but this
is your fault
so
is this what good content is supposed to
be or yeah so
if you act you know body
don't be surprised the best deals in all
of haram
don't be surprised if you got to
discount yourself right
my text no i can't see it it's at the
top
show it to me show it to me
that [ __ ] they removed the hotline
what
what is it is it the suicide hotline
[Laughter]
what hotline
the rejection
what else do you guys want to know
no questions you got it all figured out
yeah people pay me for this stuff you
can get it for free right here
no no not that's no i got like advice
i'm like dude i'd rather pay for it oh
my god
oh my god not
hannah that would be prostitution no no
i'm not likely fans
why would you oh my gosh hannah a few
months ago you should have asked me
would you be mad if i started an only
fans and i said no i know i was kidding
though i wasn't actually going to start
an oldie fans when i turned 18 i'm just
signing up to get myself a good sugar
daddy no don't do don't sell yourself
why not i have a body might as well use
it oh my god no no don't do that because
it depends like the type of husband you
get like depends on the choices you make
so those people are rich they look happy
what do you mean who's oh sugar you want
to marry like an old guy you could get
older
oh i have a sugar daddy why don't you
just date older
and then like you because that's aiming
for something without the other person
knowing having a sugar daddy
is it's that aiming it's like you're in
a relationship so then they get sex and
you get their resources like for life
that's like that's what they don't they
don't talk or i can give sugar daddy
that pays me to be there okay it doesn't
require sex i hope you're
oh eva those aren't real girls lie about
that stuff option on the website
to click no sex or sex
wait you've been on the website
eva that's how you get killed i'm like i
didn't sign up because i wasn't 18 and
they were ready to take a picture with
your id
okay do you hear what you're saying
i do if you're not an idiot i'm not
gonna go meet some random guy
well how else would you what
okay maddie got robbed when she did that
just so you know maddie tried to do what
you're doing like the the no nothing for
sugar daddy
she got robbed who's maddie
cousin
well maddie's also on like a million
different drugs oh my god okay
eva you'll be down that path
why would you get a sugar daddy when you
have rich parents
because i'm gonna make us work it's like
the worst type of yeah but like you have
a fallback it's not like you're scared
you're gonna eat they're not gonna let
you starve to death
i was here slaving all day to make
minimum wage oh my god
any other questions any other questions
we got
nothing not even like no but it's really
funny these girls i work with two of
them are like black and it's really
funny because they call me and skyler
like their n-word all day and it's so
funny what is it what does that have to
do with anything what could you take the
topic so actually a lot oh no no we
gotta stay on topic okay
so another thing you should know about
sex right
girls get way more attached during sex
because we release oxytocin
how long would it take to dig a six foot
hole
why are you asking
dad hasn't escaped hannah are you
claustrophobic by any chance what no
good
all right guys i'm gonna continue this
probably make this a series before i go
to england give them like a sex fact
sex facts don't leave england when you
go stay there
she doesn't mean it she loves me i do
sure
okay guys you can always suck more
hotline bad breath hotline
that's not funny
oh my god okay
i remember divorce hotline
yes oh my gosh okay guys subscribe
please